tal vez ya tengan una idea de qué es una
célula y tal vez ya sepan que es la
unidad más básica de la vida algunos
dicen que tal vez los virus son la
unidad más básica de la vida pero al
menos todos los organismos vivos como
nosotros estamos hechos de células y
todos los organismos vivos tienen por lo
menos una célula por eso se dice que es
la unidad más básica de la vida por
ejemplo yo que estoy haciendo este vídeo
estoy hecha de decenas de trillones de
células ahora un concepto equivocado muy
común es que las células tienen que ser
pequeñas y bueno si son muy pequeñas
algunas células tienen una longitud de
un micrómetro y eso es una millonésima
de metro o también podemos decir que es
una milésima de milímetro pero cuando
pensamos en algo tan pequeño
muchas veces suponemos que debe de ser
algo muy simple y la verdad es que
estaríamos mal si suponemos que una
célula es simple miren aquí tenemos la
imagen de la célula de una leva
y podemos ver que está brotando esto me
ayuda para comenzar a mostrarles un poco
la complejidad de cualquier célula hay
otros vídeos en los que hablamos de
diferentes tipos de células y de los
diferentes tipos de estructuras que
podemos encontrar en las células en
comparación con otras en este caso
tenemos una célula eucariota hablaremos
más sobre ellas en otros vídeos por el
momento podemos decir que todas las
células tienen una membrana que las
separa del mundo exterior supongamos que
esta es la membrana aquí tenemos una
imagen de la sección transversal de esta
célula pero ustedes pueden imaginar su
versión tridimensional esta es la
membrana celular que de alguna manera
ayuda a definir la célula y en general
lo que se encuentra dentro de la
membrana celular es considerado como
citoplasma citoplasma
muchas veces escucharán a hablar del
término cito sol pero el citoplasma no
solamente incluye el fluido sino también
todo lo que se encuentra en el fluido
mientras que el cito sol solamente se
refiere al fluido ok
como ya dijimos esta es una célula de
levadura y es un tipo de célula
eucariota que estudiaremos con mayor
profundidad en otros vídeos pero
dependiendo de la complejidad de una
célula podemos decir que una de las
características de las células
eucariotas es que tienen un núcleo unido
a la membrana y lo podemos encontrar
aquí esta no es una característica de
todas las células pero la razón por la
que se los mencionó en este vídeo es
porque oficialmente el citoplasma no
incluye todo lo que se encuentra dentro
del núcleo en una célula eucariota a
esto se le llama núcleo plasma
hablaremos más sobre eso en otros vídeos
otra característica que es muy común en
todas las células es el concepto del
ribosoma
la imagen está llena de ribosomas todos
estos pequeños puntos rojos son los
ribosomas y tal vez digan guau son muy
pequeños comparados con esta célula que
de por sí ya es pequeña y bueno si son
muy pequeños pero además consisten en
arn y proteínas complejas y su función
principal es producir proteínas producir
proteínas los ribosomas son como las
fábricas de proteínas de los organismos
vivos que toman la información genética
en forma de rn y producen proteínas como
podemos ver esta célula está llena de
ribosomas en otro vídeo hablaremos de
los diferentes tipos de ribosomas otra
cosa que es muy común en la mayoría de
las células es la información genética y
normalmente esa información genética es
almacenada como adn ahora
he dicho que en la mayoría de las
células porque resulta que incluso en
nuestros cuerpos los glóbulos rojos
maduros en la sangre carecen de adn y
existen otras células a las que les pasa
lo mismo pero en general para que una
célula funcione y se replique necesita
información genética y esa información
es almacenada en el adn eso sucede en
las células procariotas y eucariotas las
células procariotas son aquellas en las
que el núcleo no está bien definido y su
material genético son los llamados
organelos que son estas sub estructuras
de las células pero hablaremos más sobre
eso en otros vídeos en una célula
procariotas el adn flota libremente en
el citoplasma mientras que para la
mayoría de las células eucariotas el adn
se encuentra dentro del núcleo y forma
parte del núcleo plasma y bueno lo
último que me gustaría que veamos es la
escala como ya dije antes las células
son pequeñas
en esta imagen de la célula de una
levadura un micrómetro es
aproximadamente esto supongamos que esto
equivale a un micrómetro y para poner
esto en contexto digamos que es el ancho
de un cabello humano aunque eso depende
del tipo de cabello y de si es muy
delgado o muy grueso pero supongamos que
aquí tenemos un cabello humano y su
ancho en cualquier parte va desde los 20
hasta los 180 micrómetros un cabello
grueso es de aproximadamente 180
micrómetros entonces una forma de pensar
en esto es que podemos tomar
aproximadamente 20 células de levadura
que de hecho no son las células más
pequeñas pero si tomamos 20 o 30 células
de estas podemos alinear las de un lado
al otro en el grosor de un cabello eso
es increíble porque aún en esta escala
vemos que podemos tener esa complejidad
y aunque esta imagen no le haga justicia
a la complejidad existen todo tipo de
estructuras en el interior de todo esto
que no alcanzamos a ver y que ayudan a
transportar y mover cosas por todos
lados y que le dan la estructura a la
célula pero vamos a dejarlo hasta aquí
en futuros vídeos veremos con
profundidad qué son las células
eucariotas y qué son las células
procariotas veremos cómo se mueven y
cómo trabajan juntas nos vemos en otro
vídeo